beide hätten wir drei zusammen
trinkspiele dringt us players vielleicht
nicht mit tribute kommen wir zum spiel
nummer
hier habt ihr dieses spiel ist klatschen
die revolution in sachen ratespiele wie
spielkarten mit 25 verschiedenen
anweisungen lustigen aufgaben sportfest
war
außerdem reizt ich bin sehr bereit dass
sie kann sagen und das ist gemacht in so
ja aber die hat sich eine und das gleich
partner
es sitzt das einmal ein spiel nur in
schwarz klatsch partnersuche die einen
beliebigen mitspieler als klatsch
partner aus jedes mal wenn du klatschen
muss ist ein cloud partner ebenfalls zum
klatschen verpflichtet ihr bleibt so
lang als partner bis eine neue cloud
partner karte gezogen
ene mene miste es rappelt in der kiste
und und und
glaubst geschehen vergibt einen
klatscher an die mitspieler ich ja klar
du musst mit klatschen
du bist der klatsch meister also ich
wenn ein mitspieler auf deine fragen
antwortet muss er sofort klatschen immer
wieder das gleiche aber dass das so
bleibt solange er gleich mal ist der
bisher die neue clubmeister klar gezogen
wird heißt wenn ich eine frage stellt
und beantwortet dann muss diejenige
person trinken vergessen dass träume als
klatsche reaktions karte friere deine
bewegung im laufe der nächsten rund
spontan ein alle mitspieler müssen dann
auch schnell ihre bewegung einfrieren
als klatsche dann flüssig jahren direkt
nachdem ich diese kabel muss so lange
offen liegen bleiben bis sie aus
gespielt hast ok hp crazy also ich hab
das gleiche wie man das aber nicht
aufhören mit meiner bewegung du bist
hier beide aber muss es so sein dass man
schon eigentlich redet oder so und dann
nichts mehr macht echt weil das einfach
blöd wenn du nur so da sitzt und dann
der andere muss schon so eine extra
bewegung mit den plätzen im prinzip das
erst wenn du so etwas hat es momentan
ganz verdeckt habe
[Musik]
mist frage karte klatsch geschenke
verteilt 3-klatsche oder der mensch wie
du darfst auch alle 3 klatsche auf ein
einzelbild treffen darf auch gemein sein
also ihr müsst ihr beide trinken
klatschen okay ich klatsche und jetzt
ein gutes trinkspiel platz beim suchen
der ein beliebiges wort ausrechnen muss
toilette rosette kokette zigarette
komplette nein du musst klatschen
es ist wie jemand der sehr blöd ist sagt
ist es so ich weiß nicht dass
geantwortet
[Musik]
ich glaube erst davon in schockstarre
verfallen weil das immer noch offen
du hast noch was gesagt er habe dem land
von der clubmeister der klatsch klatsch
[Musik]
seite ragen stelle geschliffen klatsche
lege deine daumen im laufe der nächsten
runde unauffällig auf den tisch alle
müssen auch schnell agieren da auf den
tisch legen dann haben sie mich wieder
aus klatschen
er musste gleich in die augen dann
wünsche ich mir bei monat immer noch
fällt das der klatschen meister ganz
schön wie heute wenn er hierbei schlicht
und einfach nur oben steht zum beispiel
ich richtig dass klatsch thema sucht ihr
ein thema aus und beginne eine
aufzählung dann wird diese option der
reihe nach im uhrzeigersinn fortgesetzt
wenn die auktion nicht weiterführen kann
oder etwas wiederholt muss klatschen
beispiel schauspieler obstsorten soll
geht ihre beine in der bundesliga steht
inmitten biersorten songs michael
jackson
haushaltsgeräte planeten würde jetzt
meine ryan clark schnitzen tiere dem
langen schwanz gepackt und das hätte ich
elefant reicher denn dann ja doch
wirklich groß dann ist er im verhältnis
zum so lang dass hier sehr kurz ist ist
der ist der start dem zeitweilig wir
haben über trinken versuche die
angelegenheit mit dem klatschen musste
bleibt so lange gespart habe ist eine
neue cloud partnerkarte gepaart mit über
außerdem sind gemeint war
du bist meine party
und du musst mit regen ich meine was ich
durchmache hätte das soll mal zur
abwechslung mal mit gefühl hat auch der
kinder angela merkel er ist das
interessant das geil ich mag das mache
ich am meisten musste ja
klatschgeschichte rc lens 2
[Musik]
wir reden erst mal auf rom leidet
also noch freibier hallo klatscht
beschwerde des ist nun müssen alle
mitglieder tippen welche story war und
welche story freiheit stärker sei nicht
etwas richtig erraten was mache dann
musst du nicht trinken aber da trinke
sagte mantel dieser geschichten ist
mallorca geschichte numero uno ich bin
in einem bekannten club in kanada feiern
gegangen was kanada ich war da und bin
wegen meinen kollegen weil ich war habe
immer männer urlaub gemacht und ich bin
wegen meinen kollegen raus gezogen
worden aus dem klub ich war nicht der
verursacher aber einer der kollegen hat
stress gemacht und dann bin ich von den
türstehern rausgeworfen worden hatte
noch eine leichte körperliche
auseinandersetzung mit den und das war
bis dato die einzige körperliche
auseinandersetzungen die ich jemals hat
gesehen wo 2 ich war in kanada und war
feiern und in unserer freundes gruppe
von jungs war einer immer mit dabei der
nicht so der hit von allen war der aber
trotzdem immer dabei und dieser junge
mann
ist in einem club über ein geländer
gesprungen
auf den dancefloor und ist aber erwischt
wurden von der security und rausgeworfen
wurden aus dem klub aber weil wir jung
und agil und fresh waren hatten wir
mädels dabei und uns ist das nicht
aufgefallen
nach hause gefahren und haben den erst
am nächsten tag um 7 uhr morgens in
einem geraden am anderen ende der stadt
in einem golfclub gefunden
bis 22 aber es ist die wahrheit nicht
wahr war okay
ja die zweite service bietet
[Applaus]
das trifft wie er würden hierbei dritten
2000 xp als mutter dass wir zwei
dominosteine daraus gezogen haben fünf
karten von dem ich je gespielt habe eine
stunde später und viereinhalb stunden
sind das letzte detail ansehen und für
morgen auf jeden fall wieder irgendwie
dazwischen einfach adoptiert haben auch
tracks oder samstag am brennen oder weil
es komplett einfach nicht noch mehr
trinken
wir klatschen 5 ist alles die polizei
konnte wenig zu laut und sagst du zu
sehen erst mal bevor wir reinkommen sich
erst mal fragen was haben sie gedacht
vollauf gewachsen
ich glaube sein demnächst können
es ist pantomime
wir haben wieder ein vielfältig
diese zahl wollte zeigt einmal die zahl
an und was gemacht werden soll ich noch
eine runde auf dem wir jetzt in die
kamera gehalten
3 und zeigen stift köflach duftstoff
pantomime spitze schafft ich bin heute
glaube aufgelegt raul krauthausen längst
verloren
das spielt für mich besonders kunden 4
und pantomime denn ich war der coole
1234 akku leer geht so zum start und da
dein handy auf um deine freunde
erreichen zu können war aber trotzdem
muss er die karte nehmen und 4
pantomimisch zeigen - zeit beginnt jetzt
erst
[Musik]
verlassen so klar wie spiel mit den
richtigen
[Applaus]
dass das zeichnen ein recht 23
[Musik]
sonne mond und sterne wie viele wörter
rot sondern der sonnen oder sowas sein
morgen wartet so war ein zufall dass er
gehört habe
zwei wörter das wort nach spitze
klassenclown
alex hat dort ist das 1 1 ist das wahr
was erlebt aus dem album folge sieben
von dieses feature phones entziehen
ok zeichnet 32 ein haus quadrat quadrat
viereck
lippenherpes oberlippenbart oberliga
[Musik]
vorbei frühstücksflocken
frühstücksflocken und das hätte ich
halte ganz anders gemacht
[Musik]
sorry leute aber nicht so gut haben aber
eigentlich das spiel getestet oder ich
finde es auch nicht so krass also das
andere war schon heftiger muss man sagen
haben wir schon auch ein anfang ist aber
dass nicht anfängt langsam ist also
gerade im warnungen kompletter kollaps
von allen systemen so aber das ist von
mir so scheiße aber 35 ich liebe halt
zeichnen nicht überzeugt das war also
ich meine
verlasst kannst du eigentlich zeigen wie
es geht eigentlich das spiel weiß das
ganz genau ich finds geil betankung taxi
ist da sucht ja ein spieler der sein
getränk mit die echsen muss müssen wir
jetzt entscheiden was war das beste
spiel wir müssen jetzt
ein bass patrick obrist war das beste
spiel kubb liga besser ist ein hund
wieder auf das war zu lasch dafür
herrschen wahlhelfer klatschen aber will
kuppel hat die karten die sehr gut waren
und noch das spiel da nebenbei weißt du
dass man nicht ganz fangen ja ich bin
auch zwischen klatschen und rufen also
eigentlich mag ich wollte fragt weil die
gesagt liebe pantomime und zeichnen aber
das ist nur so ein anfangs für sehr
spezielle lustigen spieleabend da nichts
gegessen
zwischendurch stimmt wir haben jetzt
haben wir drei stunden gespielt es ist
ein uhr morgens was wir hatten
ich hoffe natürlich dass euch das video
gefallen hat wir hatten mega viel spaß
beim spielen und testen und schreib doch
mal in die kommentare in welches spiel
ist euer lieblings trinkspiel kennen die
kommentare und dann sehen wir uns wieder
beim nächsten video mal gucken was es
sein wird wahrscheinlich wieder ein
kommt jetzt die bald aber mal gucken mal
gucken